We've been on our full protocol for eight weeks, my boyfriend, who has squandered so
carcinoma on his tonsil, has been swallowing better for at least two weeks now, and therefore
has gained a couple of pounds via a. With my dress cancer, I haven't detected any
shrinkage in tumor size. Is it too early? Well, remember, you might not detect shrinkage
in your tumor size, so that is, you know, the, the goal of cancer care, whether you're
doing standards of care or alternative care is to get it to stop growing. I mean, it's
going to get it to stop acting like cancer. But you want, the ultimate goal is you want
your body to clean it up and to get rid of it and to dissolve it, break it down and kill
those cells and then it would shrink. But some cancers tend not to do that. It just
is what it is. Some cancers will just stop growing. And hey, that's a win as long as it's
not blocking a lumen, like if you're cold or something or impede on, you know, blood flow
or something, it's still a win. So, but you do need to, I don't know that there's an
error. Is it too early to know? You just, you just want to see some progress in at least
stopping the growth. That's, that's something that you want to be seeing. So you want to
be able to have a reliable way to monitor that as well. I feel fine, but the cancer never
made me ever feel sick. So I can't judge it by that. By tumor or the right is near the
surface and quite large. Like five centimeters. So it makes me nervous. But I know it was there
for at least two years, misdiagnosed. So maybe I need a patient to result. I don't think you're
being a patient. You want to see some change. You don't want it to be getting larger. That's
that's the, that's the real thing. You want it to even stay in the same size if you're like, I don't
notice it 80 different in size. But I want it to shrink. Well, that I would say, you know, continue
to be patient to continue to move forward. The other side, the tumors are much smaller, but on the
underside of my breast and closer to my chest full. I live nodes haven't shrunk. I have one on each
side that are larger and sometimes hurt. I don't know what to do next. Just never had to deal with
anything like this and talking to my conventional docs always terrifies me. And there really no help
because I want to do, you know, go and alternative route. I don't even know if I convince them to run
any more tests because they refuse to run my tumor markers. I asked my psychiatrist to do it for me. The
only ones that popped was the CA 15 3 at 29.8 and 25 was the upper limit. And I did that five weeks ago.
So if you have a tumor marker test that shows positive meaning above the normal range, then you can
use that for a marker. You can even use it to a marker test if it shows if it's within the normal
range, but it's at the high end. Or you can run your tumor markers and let's say they're all within
the normal range and then you run them again. They're still within the normal range, but they've changed
dramatically. You certainly don't look at if it's if it's moved through four points, five points,
but if it's jumped 10 points, then you start going up. So those are valuable things to look at.
I don't know what to do next. Well, tumor marker tests are inexpensive to run so you could run them
on a monthly basis to if you can't really assess any other way. So be patient to another
cheek swab. I don't think to it another cheek swab at this time is necessary. Looking at some other
ways to test objectivity would be something. Maybe you can, if your chiropractor can ask for
an ultrasound, that would be another objective test. So maybe ask your chiropractor that.
And like I said, yes, tumor markers rerun. Yes, you could do that on a monthly basis.
I bones get MRI and CT in mid September didn't indicate the cancer was anywhere else, but I don't
know how this works and are all the supplements, et cetera. I'm taking putting up a reasonable strong
shield against metastasis. Well, you're putting up the best shield you can from an alternative
perspective. Even if you did all that the oncologist has to do still doesn't mean that's you know
doing everything you can from the way your body's dealing with the cancer. So there's lots of
people that do everything their oncologist tells them to do what they still get metastasis
that but different days. So you just, you know, are just trying to use your best judgment in the
recording. Sorry for the long question, but I need help navigating that I don't even know what
questions to ask. The practitioner who is muscle testing us each week says our organ systems are testing
strong, indicating that we're on the right path. But they do not have as many of the same kind of
patients. I need to watch certain videos, read certain sections in your book. Again, so please
just let me know what those would be. I just don't know where to start. Well, I think you are moving
forward. You're doing the right thing. I think the biggest thing is you want to be using your best
objective way and subjective way of measuring if there's any growth. So if you if your tumors are very
palpable and you can kind of, you know, with the best reasonable judgment tell if it's growing or not
that might be your best unit of measure right now. Certainly since the CA 153 was positive, I would
run that again. And it's there's value in running your your other blood tests just a CBC and a
can take that amount of panel in the three months as well. That your chiropractor should be able to